with every passing day the democratic
party reveals what its
true intentions are though they claim to
be the party of science and facts
their advocacy and voting patterns show
they're anything but
yesterday the senate voted on a bill
that would require a doctor to use
all of his skills to preserve the life
of a child
born alive after an attempted abortion
the bill came in reaction to grisly
macabre efforts in new york
virginia and elsewhere to essentially
legalize
infanticide governor ralph northam of
virginia
specifically verbally supported efforts
to legalize it
so trump called him out during the state
of the union
we had the case of the governor of
virginia
where he stated he would execute a baby
after birth
to defend the dignity of every person
i am asking congress to pass legislation
to prohibit the late term abortion
of children well there was essentially
little to no response from the democrats
in the room stone face
nancy just sat there well the senate
attempted yesterday to do something
about this democrat embrace of
infanticide and
hold doctors accountable so my
colleagues across the aisle need to
decide
where they'll take their cues on these
moral questions
on the one hand there are a few extreme
voices who've decided that some
newborn labs are more disposable than
others
on the other side is the entire rest of
the country
i want to ask each and every one of my
colleagues whether or not we're okay
with infanticide
this language is blunt i recognize that
and it's too blunt for many people
in this body but frankly that is what
we're talking about here today
now in the end all but three democrats
voted against permitting the bill to
proceed shameless
every one of the announced 2020
democratic presidential candidates
voted no senators gillibrand
booker harris klobuchar warren
and bernie sanders voted to support the
wanton extermination of children already
born
along with planned parenthood they claim
that the bill would limit
reproductive rights and in the words of
senator patty murray
it's a vote on yet another attack from
our republican colleagues on
women's health and their right to access
safe
legal abortion this time in the form of
an anti-doctor
anti-woman anti-family piece of
legislation
nice try patty aunty doctor andy woman
andy family
a family usually requires a child an
infanticide usually requires
the taking of a child's life doesn't it
and what marie didn't mention is that
she and her party's opposition to this
common sense bill
is itself anti-science
we have a viable child that has been
born
in what way is it anti-woman or
anti-family to protect the life of that
child
it's craziness now the president
correctly summarized the vote in a pair
of tweets yesterday
the democrat position on abortion is now
so extreme
that they don't mind executing babies
after birth
this will be remembered as one of the
most shocking votes
in the history of congress
but my friends once a party embraces
this nihilism this
dark religion by treating abortion
itself like a sacrament
all reason goes out the window what
happened to safe legal and rare
their unwavering defense of abortion on
demand
even if it leads to infanticide or let's
say the embrace of
other issues like gender fluidity even
if that leads to rank unfairness we're
going to get that
get to that issue later on in the show
it's akin to a secular sharia law among
the left
you deviate from what the social justice
warriors stipulate today
and they'll decapitate you in the
workplace
and in school if they have their way
these people are fanatics they're
zealots
hell bent on a complete upending of the
social order
an upending of just about everything
that embodies or even
comes close to embodying tradition
leftist icon feminist gloria steinem was
on the today show promoting a book of
old essays
one in particular written in the 1980s
suggested that the republican party and
hitler's views had a lot in common
on a more serious note to put it mildly
is
why hitler was actually elected and he
was elected
and he campaigned against abortion i
mean that was he
padlocked the family planning clinics
okay so that is still
relevant in terms of the right wing well
i'm afraid gloria is getting a bit dotty
in her old age
she essentially is arguing that in order
to save humanity
you have to kill off more humans and
notice how steinem
practices the art of self-projection
hitler just like planned parenthood
practiced and defended mass
extermination
all in the name of racial purity which
is exactly what the founder of planned
parenthood believed
margaret sanger believed deeply in
eugenics
check out this article from 1926
about sanger's advocacy for birth
control clinics
she said we want a world freer
happier cleaner we want a race
of thoroughbreds it shouldn't surprise
you
that sanger established her first full
service clinic
in harlem in 1930. but why harlem
well as the washington times explains
that's where a lot of the black people
she often referred to as
human weeds lived sanger described it as
an experimental clinic established for
the benefit
of colored people well for her the word
benefit really just meant
elimination and in her infamous letter
to clarence gamble of procter
gamble it was about the need to use the
cover
of ministers to set up these clinics
she wrote to him the most successful
educational approach to their population
is through a religious appeal we don't
want the word to get out that we might
want we want to exterminate the negro
population and the minister
is the man who can straighten out that
idea if it should occur
to their more rebellious members
can you believe that was written the
left then
and the left today has this insatiable
appetite
for this death culture which by the way
reminds me of another baby story
what have you done to it what have you
done to its eyes
he has his father's eyes what have you
done to him
satan is his father not guy
the left's dogmatic adherence to their
dark gospel
means they'll never disavow this
undeniable
racist or purge her from their history
new york even named a street after
sanger
yeah it's called margaret sanger way
and it's not just the old war horses of
the left preaching this deadly creed the
young
upstarts have joined the congregation
even when cooking alone in an empty
apartment
there's scientific consensus that the
lives of children are going to be very
difficult
and it does lead i think young people to
have a legitimate question you know
should
is it okay to still have children a
second
the lives of children are going to be
very difficult sure are if they're not
born
what scientific consensus
it's called eventual human extinction
professor
and for people who claim to be concerned
about being on the right side of history
they seem to be running in the opposite
direction
nbc reported on millennials who just say
no
to babies they did it last month i think
i just had a lot of other
aspirations in mind i wasn't i mean
babies are a lot of work
and i wasn't really willing to take on
half that work well no repercussions for
that type of thinking right
some say it puts our country in jeopardy
of not having a strong enough workforce
in the years to come
another possible impact though we risk
having fewer people to help care for the
nation's growing
elderly population but who cares about
them i'm not sure margaret sanger would
care much about them they're disposable
as well
those old people have robot bots to feed
them by then right oh come on please
but there is some sunshine in the
forecast my friends
a new marist poll finds that after a 17
point gap
last month americans are now just as
likely to
identify as pro-life as pro-choice
and democrats are where the movement is
happening
last month 20 of democrats claim to be
pro-life this month
that number is up to 34 percent massive
increase
and americans are overwhelmingly
believing that third trimester abortions
should be outlawed 71 to 25
the poor people in the 25 percent but
we'll pray for them
now the left blinded by their dogmatic
attachment to abortion
can't see that americans don't want what
they're selling
if aoc really wanted to be edgy
she'd couple her love of creation and
all things green
with a love of life and defending the
most defenseless
and that's the angle